The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
Okay so I'd like to begin the
second lecture by reminding you
what we did last time.
So last time, we
defined the derivative
as the slope of a tangent line.
So that was our
geometric point of view
and we also did a
couple of computations.
We worked out that the
derivative of 1 / x was -1 /
x^2.
And we also computed the
derivative of x to the nth
power for n = 1, 2, etc.,
and that turned out to be x,
I'm sorry, nx^(n-1).
So that's what we did
last time, and today I
want to finish up with
other points of view
on what a derivative is.
So this is extremely
important, it's
almost the most important thing
I'll be saying in the class.
But you'll have to think about
it again when you start over
and start using calculus
in the real world.
So again we're talking
about what is a derivative
and this is just a
continuation of last time.
So, as I said last time,
we talked about geometric
interpretations, and today
what we're gonna talk about
is rate of change
as an interpretation
of the derivative.
So remember we drew graphs
of functions, y = f(x)
and we kept track of the change
in x and here the change in y,
let's say.
And then from this new point
of view a rate of change,
keeping track of the rate
of change of x and the rate
of change of y, it's the
relative rate of change
we're interested in, and that's
delta y / delta x and that
has another interpretation.
This is the average change.
Usually we would think of that,
if x were measuring time and so
the average and that's
when this becomes a rate,
and the average is over
the time interval delta x.
And then the limiting
value is denoted dy/dx
and so this one is the
average rate of change
and this one is the
instantaneous rate.
Okay, so that's
the point of view
that I'd like to
discuss now and give you
just a couple of examples.
So, let's see.
Well, first of all, maybe some
examples from physics here.
So q is usually the
name for a charge,
and then dq/dt is
what's known as current.
So that's one physical example.
A second example, which is
probably the most tangible one,
is we could denote the
letter s by distance
and then the rate of change
is what we call speed.
So those are the
two typical examples
and I just want to
illustrate the second example
in a little bit more
detail because I think
it's important to have some
visceral sense of this notion
of instantaneous speed.
And I get to use the example of
this very building to do that.
Probably you know,
or maybe you don't,
that on Halloween
there's an event that
takes place in this
building or really
from the top of
this building which
is called the pumpkin drop.
So let's illustrates this
idea of rate of change
with the pumpkin drop.
So what happens is,
this building-- well
let's see here's the building,
and here's the dot, that's
the beautiful grass out on
this side of the building,
and then there's
some people up here
and very small
objects, well they're
not that small when
you're close to them, that
get dumped over the side there.
And they fall down.
You know everything at MIT
or a lot of things at MIT
are physics experiments.
That's the pumpkin drop.
So roughly speaking,
the building
is about 300 feet
high, we're down here
on the first usable floor.
And so we're going to
use instead of 300 feet,
just for convenience
purposes we'll
use 80 meters because that makes
the numbers come out simply.
So we have the height
which starts out
at 80 meters at time 0 and then
the acceleration due to gravity
gives you this formula
for h, this is the height.
So at time t = 0, we're up
at the top, h is 80 meters,
the units here are meters.
And at time t = 4 you
notice, 5 * 4^2 is 80.
I picked these numbers
conveniently so
that we're down at the bottom.
Okay, so this notion
of average change here,
so the average change, or
the average speed here,
maybe we'll call it
the average speed,
since that's-- over this time
that it takes for the pumpkin
to drop is going to be
the change in h divided
by the change in t.
Which starts out at, what
does it start out as?
It starts out as 80, right?
And it ends at 0.
So actually we have
to do it backwards.
We have to take 0 - 80
because the first value is
the final position
and the second value
is the initial position.
And that's divided by
4 - 0; times 4 seconds
minus times 0 seconds.
And so that of course is
-20 meters per second.
So the average speed of this
guy is 20 meters a second.
Now, so why did I
pick this example?
Because, of course, the
average, although interesting,
is not really what
anybody cares about who
actually goes to the event.
All we really care about
is the instantaneous speed
when it hits the pavement
and so that's can
be calculated at the bottom.
So what's the
instantaneous speed?
That's the derivative,
or maybe to be
consistent with the notation
I've been using so far,
that's d/dt of h.
All right?
So that's d/dt of h.
Now remember we have
formulas for these things.
We can differentiate
this function now.
We did that yesterday.
So we're gonna take the rate of
change and if you take a look
at it, it's just the rate
of change of 80 is 0,
minus the rate change for
this -5t^2, that's minus 10t.
So that's using the fact
that d/dt of 80 is equal to 0
and d/dt of t^2 is equal to 2t.
The special case...
Well I'm cheating
here, but there's
a special case that's obvious.
I didn't throw it in over here.
The case n = 2 is that
second case there.
But the case n = 0 also works.
Because that's constants.
The derivative of
a constant is 0.
And then the factor n there's
0 and that's consistent.
And actually if you look
at the formula above it
you'll see that it's
the case of n = -1.
So we'll get a larger pattern
soon enough with the powers.
Okay anyway.
Back over here we have
our rate of change
and this is what it is.
And at the bottom, at
that point of impact,
we have t = 4 and so h',
which is the derivative,
is equal to -40
meters per second.
So twice as fast as
the average speed here,
and if you need to convert that,
that's about 90 miles an hour.
Which is why the police are
there at midnight on Halloween
to make sure you're all safe
and also why when you come
you have to be prepared
to clean up afterwards.
So anyway that's what happens,
it's 90 miles an hour.
It's actually the
buildings a little taller,
there's air resistance
and I'm sure you
can do a much more thorough
study of this example.
All right so now I want to give
you a couple of more examples
because time and these kinds
of parameters and variables
are not the only ones that
are important for calculus.
If it were only this kind of
physics that was involved,
then this would be a much more
specialized subject than it is.
And so I want to give you a
couple of examples that don't
involve time as a variable.
So the third example
I'll give here
is-- The letter T often
denotes temperature,
and then dT/dx would be what
is known as the temperature
gradient.
Which we really care
about a lot when
we're predicting the weather
because it's that temperature
difference that causes air flows
and causes things to change.
And then there's
another theme which
is throughout the sciences
and engineering which
I'm going to talk about under
the heading of sensitivity
of measurements.
So let me explain this.
I don't want to belabor
it because I just
am doing this in
order to introduce you
to the ideas on your
problem set which
are the first case of this.
So on problem set one
you have an example
which is based on a
simplified model of GPS,
sort of the Flat Earth Model.
And in that situation,
well, if the Earth is flat
it's just a horizontal
line like this.
And then you have a satellite,
which is over here, preferably
above the earth, and the
satellite or the system
knows exactly where the point
directly below the satellite
is.
So this point is
treated as known.
And I'm sitting here
with my little GPS device
and I want to know where I am.
And the way I
locate where I am is
I communicate with this
satellite by radio signals
and I can measure this distance
here which is called h.
And then system will compute
this horizontal distance which
is L. So in other
words what is measured,
so h measured by radios,
radio waves and a clock,
or various clocks.
And then L is deduced from h.
And what's critical in
all of these systems
is that you don't
know h exactly.
There's an error in h
which will denote delta h.
There's some degree
of uncertainty.
The main uncertainty in
GPS is from the ionosphere.
But there are lots
of corrections
that are made of all kinds.
And also if you're
inside a building
it's a problem to measure it.
But it's an extremely
important issue,
as I'll explain in a second.
So the idea is we
then get at delta
L is estimated by considering
this ratio delta L/delta
h which is going
to be approximately
the same as the derivative
of L with respect to h.
So this is the thing that's
easy because of course it's
calculus.
Calculus is the
easy part and that
allows us to deduce something
about the real world that's
close by over here.
So the reason why you should
care about this quite a bit
is that it's used all the
time to land airplanes.
So you really do care
that they actually
know to within a few feet or
even closer where your plane is
and how high up it
is and so forth.
All right.
So that's it for the
general introduction
of what a derivative is.
I'm sure you'll be
getting used to this
in a lot of different contexts
throughout the course.
And now we have to get back
down to some rigorous details.
Okay, everybody happy with
what we've got so far?
Yeah?
Student: How did you get
the equation for height?
Professor: Ah good question.
The question was how did I
get this equation for height?
I just made it up because
it's the formula from physics
that you will learn when
you take 8.01 and, in fact,
it has to do with the fact
that this is the speed if you
differentiate
another time you get
acceleration and
acceleration due to gravity
is 10 meters per second.
Which happens to be the
second derivative of this.
But anyway I just pulled it
out of a hat from your physics
class.
So you can just say see 8.01 .
All right, other questions?
All right, so let's go on now.
Now I have to be a little bit
more systematic about limits.
So let's do that now.
So now what I'd like to talk
about is limits and continuity.
And this is a warm
up for deriving
all the rest of the formulas,
all the rest of the formulas
that I'm going to
need to differentiate
every function you know.
Remember, that's our goal
and we only have about a week
left so we'd better get started.
So first of all there is
what I will call easy limits.
So what's an easy limit?
An easy limit is something like
the limit as x goes to 4 of x
plus 3 over x^2 + 1.
And with this kind of limit all
I have to do to evaluate it is
to plug in x = 4 because,
so what I get here is 4 + 3
divided by 4^2 + 1.
And that's just 7 / 17.
And that's the end of it.
So those are the easy limits.
The second kind of limit -
well so this isn't the only
second kind of limit but I
just want to point this out,
it's very important - is that:
derivatives are are always
harder than this.
You can't get away
with nothing here.
So, why is that?
Well, when you
take a derivative,
you're taking the limit
as x goes to x_0 of f(x),
well we'll write it all
out in all its glory.
Here's the formula
for the derivative.
Now notice that if you plug in
x = x:0, always gives 0 / 0.
So it just basically
never works.
So we always are going
to need some cancellation
to make sense out of the limit.
Now in order to make things
a little easier for myself
to explain what's
going on with limits
I need to introduce just
one more piece of notation.
What I'm gonna
introduce here is what's
known as a left-hand
and a right limit.
If I take the limit as x tends
to x_0 with a plus sign here
of some function, this is what's
known as the right-hand limit.
And I can display it visually.
So what does this mean?
It means practically
the same thing
as x tends to x_0 except there
is one more restriction which
has to do with this plus
sign, which is we're going
from the plus side of x_0.
That means x is bigger than x_0.
And I say right-hand, so
there should be a hyphen here,
right-hand limit because
on the number line,
if x_0 is over here
the x is to the right.
All right?
So that's the right-hand limit.
And then this being the
left side of the board,
I'll put on the right side
of the board the left limit,
just to make things confusing.
So that one has the
minus sign here.
I'm just a little dyslexic
and I hope you're not.
So I may have gotten that wrong.
So this is the left-hand
limit, and I'll draw it.
So of course that just
means x goes to x_0 but x is
to the left of x_0 .
And again, on the number
line, here's the x_0
and the x is on the
other side of it.
Okay, so those two
notations are going
to help us to clarify
a bunch of things.
It's much more
convenient to have
this extra bit of
description of limits
than to just consider
limits from both sides.
Okay so I want to give
an example of this.
And also an example
of how you're going to
think about these
sorts of problems.
So I'll take a function which
has two different definitions.
Say it's x + 1, when x >
0 and -x + 2, when x < 0.
So maybe put commas there.
So when x > 0, it's x + 1.
Now I can draw a
picture of this.
It's gonna be kind
of a little small
because I'm gonna try
to fit it down in here,
but maybe I'll put
the axis down below.
So at height 1, I have to
the right something of slope
1 so it goes up like this.
All right?
And then to the left of 0 I have
something which has slope -1,
but it hits the axis
at 2 so it's up here.
So I had this sort of
strange antenna figure here,
which is my graph.
Maybe I should draw these in
another color to depict that.
And then if I calculate
these two limits here,
what I see is that
the limit as x
goes to 0 from above of f(x),
that's the same as the limit
as x goes to 0 of the
formula here, x + 1.
Which turns out to be 1.
And if I take the limit, so
that's the left-hand limit.
Sorry, I told you
I was dyslexic.
This is the right, so
it's that right-hand.
Here we go.
So now I'm going from the
left, and it's f(x) again,
but now because I'm on that
side the thing I need to plug
is the other formula, -x + 2,
and that's gonna give us 2.
Now, notice that the left
and right limits, and this
is one little tiny subtlety
and it's almost the only thing
that I need you to really
pay attention to a little bit
right now, is that this, we
did not need x = 0 value.
In fact I never even told
you what f(0) was here.
If we stick it in we
could stick it in.
Okay let's say we stick
it in on this side.
Let's make it be that
it's on this side.
So that means that this point
is in and this point is out.
So that's a typical notation:
this little open circle
and this closed dot for
when you include the.
So in that case
the value of f(x)
happens to be the same
as its right-hand limit,
namely the value is
1 here and not 2.
Okay, so that's the
first kind of example.
Questions?
Okay, so now our next
job is to introduce
the definition of continuity.
So that was the
other topic here.
So we're going to define.
So f is continuous at x_0 means
that the limit of f(x) as x
tends to x_0 is
equal to f(x_0) .
Right?
So the reason why I spend
all this time paying
attention to the left and the
right and so on and so forth
and focusing is that I want you
to pay attention for one moment
to what the content
of this definition is.
What it's saying is the
following: continuous at x_0
has various ingredients here.
So the first one is
that this limit exists.
And what that means
is that there's
an honest limiting value
both from the left and right.
And they also have
to be the same.
All right, so that's
what's going on here.
And the second property
is that f(x_0) is defined.
So I can't be in one
of these situations
where I haven't
even specified what
f(x_0) is and they're equal.
Okay, so that's the situation.
Now again let me
emphasize a tricky part
of the definition of a limit.
This side, the left-hand side
is completely independent,
is evaluated by a
procedure which does not
involve the right-hand side.
These are separate things.
This one is, to evaluate it, you
always avoid the limit point.
So that's if you like a
paradox, because it's exactly
the question: is it true
that if you plug in x_0
you get the same answer as
if you move in the limit?
That's the issue that
we're considering here.
We have to make that
distinction in order
to say that these
are two, otherwise
this is just tautological.
It doesn't have any meaning.
But in fact it
does have a meaning
because one thing is evaluated
separately with reference
to all the other
points and the other
is evaluated right at
the point in question.
And indeed what
these things are,
are exactly the easy limits.
That's exactly what
we're talking about here.
They're the ones you
can evaluate this way.
So we have to make
the distinction.
And these other ones are
gonna be the ones which
we can't evaluate that way.
So these are the
nice ones and that's
why we care about them, why
we have a whole definition
associated with them.
All right?
So now what's next?
Well, I need to give you a a
little tour, very brief tour,
of the zoo of what are known
as discontinuous functions.
So sort of everything else
that's not continuous.
So, the first example here,
let me just write it down here.
It's jump discontinuities.
So what would a jump
discontinuity be?
Well we've actually
already seen it.
The jump discontinuity
is the example
that we had right there.
This is when the limit
from the left and right
exist, but are not equal.
Okay, so that's
as in the example.
Right?
In this example, the
two limits, one of them
was 1 and of them was 2.
So that's a jump discontinuity.
And this kind of issue,
of whether something
is continuous or not, may
seem a little bit technical
but it is true that people
have worried about it a lot.
Bob Merton, who was a
professor at MIT when
he did his work for the
Nobel prize in economics,
was interested in
this very issue
of whether stock
prices of various kinds
are continuous from the left
or right in a certain model.
And that was a
very serious issue
in developing the model
that priced things
that our hedge funds
use all the time now.
So left and right can really
mean something very different.
In this case left is the
past and right is the future
and it makes a big
difference whether things
are continuous from the left
or continuous from the right.
Right, is it true that
the point is here,
here, somewhere in the
middle, somewhere else.
That's a serious issue.
So the next example
that I want to give you
is a little bit more subtle.
It's what's known as a
removable discontinuity.
And so what this means is that
the limit from left and right
are equal.
So a picture of
that would be, you
have a function which is
coming along like this
and there's a hole
maybe where, who knows
either the function is undefined
or maybe it's defined up here,
and then it just continues on.
All right?
So the two limits are the same.
And then of course the function
is begging to be redefined
so that we remove that hole.
And that's why it's called
a removable discontinuity.
Now let me give you
an example of this,
or actually a
couple of examples.
So these are quite
important examples
which you will be working
with in a few minutes.
So the first is the function
g(x), which is sin x / x,
and the second will be the
function h(x), which is 1 -
cos x over x.
So we have a problem at
g(0), g(0) is undefined.
On the other hand it turns
out this function has what's
called a removable singularity.
Namely the limit as x goes
to 0 of sin x / x does exist.
In fact it's equal to 1.
So that's a very important limit
that we will work out either
at the end of this lecture or
the beginning of next lecture.
And similarly, the
limit of 1 - cos x
divided by x, as
x goes to 0, is 0.
Maybe I'll put that
a little farther
away so you can read it.
Okay, so these are
very useful facts
that we're going
to need later on.
And what they say is
that these things have
removable singularities, sorry
removable discontinuity at x
= 0.
All right so as I say, we'll
get to that in a few minutes.
Okay so are there any
questions before I move on?
Yeah?
Student: [INAUDIBLE]
Professor: The question
is: why is this true?
Is that what your question is?
The answer is it's
very, very unobvious,
I haven't shown it to you
yet, and if you were not
surprised by it then that
would be very strange indeed.
So we haven't done it yet.
You have to stay
tuned until we do.
Okay?
We haven't shown it yet.
And actually even
this other statement,
which maybe seems
stranger still,
is also not yet explained.
Okay, so we are going
to get there, as I said,
either at the end
of this lecture
or at the beginning of next.
Other questions?
All right, so let me
just continue my tour
of the zoo of discontinuities.
And, I guess, I want
to illustrate something
with the convenience of
right and left hand limits
so I'll save this board about
right and left-hand limits.
So a third type of
discontinuity is
what's known as an
infinite discontinuity.
And we've already
encountered one of these.
I'm going to draw
them over here.
Remember the
function y is 1 / x.
That's this function here.
But now I'd like to draw
also the other branch
of the hyperbola down here
and allow myself to consider
negative values of x.
So here's the graph of 1 / x.
And the convenience here
of distinguishing the left
and the right hand limits is
very important because here I
can write down that the limit
as x goes to 0+ of 1 / x.
Well that's coming from the
right and it's going up.
So this limit is infinity.
Whereas, the limit in
the other direction,
from the left, that
one is going down.
And so it's quite different,
it's minus infinity.
Now some people say that
these limits are undefined
but actually they're going in
some very definite direction.
So you should,
whenever possible,
specify what these limits are.
On the other hand, the
statement that the limit
as x goes to 0 of 1 / x is
infinity is simply wrong.
Okay, it's not that
people don't write this.
It's just that it's wrong.
It's not that they
don't write it down.
In fact you'll probably see it.
It's because people are just
thinking of the right hand
branch.
It's not that they're making
a mistake necessarily,
but anyway, it's sloppy.
And there's some sloppiness
that we'll endure
and others that
we'll try to avoid.
So here, you want to say this,
and it does make a difference.
You know, plus infinity is
an infinite number of dollars
and minus infinity is and
infinite amount of debt.
They're actually different.
They're not the same.
So, you know, this is sloppy and
this is actually more correct.
Okay, so now in
addition, I just want
to point out one more thing.
Remember, we calculated
the derivative,
and that was -1/x^2.
But, I want to draw
the graph of that
and make a few
comments about it.
So I'm going to draw
the graph directly
underneath the graph
of the function.
And notice what this graphs is.
It goes like this, it's always
negative, and it points down.
So now this may look
a little strange,
that the derivative of
this thing is this guy,
but that's because of
something very important.
And you should always remember
this about derivatives.
The derivative function looks
nothing like the function,
necessarily.
So you should just forget
about that as being an idea.
Some people feel like
if one thing goes down,
the other thing has to go down.
Just forget that intuition.
It's wrong.
What we're dealing with here,
if you remember, is the slope.
So if you have a slope
here, that corresponds
to just a place over
here and as the slope
gets a little bit
less steep, that's
why we're approaching
the horizontal axis.
The number is getting a
little smaller as we close in.
Now over here, the
slope is also negative.
It is going down and
as we get down here
it's getting more
and more negative.
As we go here the slope,
this function is going up,
but its slope is going down.
All right, so the slope is down
on both sides and the notation
that we use for that is
well suited to this left
and right business.
Namely, the limit as x
goes to 0 of -1 / x^2,
that's going to be
equal to minus infinity.
And that applies to x going
to 0+ and x going to 0-.
So both have this property.
Finally let me just
make one last comment
about these two graphs.
This function here
is an odd function
and when you take the
derivative of an odd function
you always get an even function.
That's closely related to the
fact that this 1 / x is an odd
power and-- x^1 is an odd
power and x^2 is an even power.
So all of this your intuition
should be reinforcing the fact
that these pictures look right.
Okay, now there's one
last kind of discontinuity
that I want to mention
briefly, which I will call
other ugly discontinuities.
And there are lots
and lots of them.
So one example would
be the function y = sin
1 / x, as x goes to 0.
And that looks a
little bit like this.
Back and forth and
back and forth.
It oscillates infinitely
often as we tend to 0.
There's no left or right
limit in this case.
So there is a very large
quantity of things like that.
Fortunately we're not gonna
deal with them in this course.
A lot of times in
real life there
are things that oscillate
as time goes to infinity,
but we're not going to
worry about that right now.
Okay, so that's our final
mention of a discontinuity,
and now I need to do just
one more piece of groundwork
for our formulas next time.
Namely, I want to check
for you one basic fact,
one limiting tool.
So this is going
to be a theorem.
Fortunately it's a
very short theorem
and has a very short proof.
So the theorem goes under
the name differentiable
implies continuous.
And what it says
is the following:
it says that if f is
differentiable, in other words
its-- the derivative
exists at x_0, then
f is continuous at x_0.
So, we're gonna need
this is as a tool,
it's a key step in the
product and quotient rules.
So I'd like to prove
it right now for you.
So here is the proof.
Fortunately the proof
is just one line.
So first of all, I want to
write in just the right way what
it is that we have to check.
So what we have to check is that
the limit, as x goes to x_0,
of f(x) - f(x_0) is equal to 0.
So this is what we want to know.
We don't know it
yet, but we're trying
to check whether
this is true or not.
So that's the same
as the statement
that the function is continuous
because the limit of f(x)
is supposed to be f(x_0) and
so this difference should
have limit 0.
And now, the way this
is proved is just
by rewriting it by multiplying
and dividing by (x - x_0).
So I'll rewrite the limit
as x goes to x_0 of f(x) -
f(x_0) divided by x
- x_0 times x - x_0.
Okay, so I wrote down the same
expression that I had here.
This is just the same limit,
but I multiplied and divided
by (x - x_0).
And now when I take the limit
what happens is the limit
of the first factor is f'(x_0).
That's the thing we know
exists by our assumption.
And the limit of the second
factor is 0 because the limit
as x goes to x_0 of (x
- x_0) is clearly 0 .
So that's it.
The answer is 0, which
is what we wanted.
So that's the proof.
Now there's something
exceedingly fishy-looking
about this proof and let me just
point to it before we proceed.
Namely, you're used in limits
to setting x equal to 0.
And this looks like we're
multiplying, dividing by 0,
exactly the thing
which makes all proofs
wrong in all kinds of
algebraic situations
and so on and so forth.
You've been taught
that that never works.
Right?
But somehow these
limiting tricks
have found a way around
this and let me just
make explicit what it is.
In this limit we never
are using x = x_0.
That's exactly the
one value of x that we
don't consider in this limit.
That's how limits are cooked up.
And that's sort of been
the themes so far today,
is that we don't
have to consider that
and so this multiplication
and division by this number
is legal.
It may be small, this number,
but it's always non-zero.
So this really works,
and it's really true,
and we just checked that a
differentiable function is
continuous.
So I'm gonna have to carry
out these limits, which
are very interesting 0
/ 0 limits next time.
But let's hang on for one second
to see if there any questions
before we stop.
Yeah, there is a question.
Student: [INAUDIBLE] Professor:
Repeat this proof right here?
Just say again.
Student: [INAUDIBLE]
Professor: Okay, so there
are two steps to the proof
and the step that you're
asking about is the first step.
Right?
And what I'm saying is
if you have a number,
and you multiply it by 10
/ 10 it's the same number.
If you multiply it by 3
/ 3 it's the same number.
2 / 2, 1 / 1, and so on.
So it is okay to
change this to this,
it's exactly the same thing.
That's the first step.
Yes?
Student: [INAUDIBLE]
Professor: Shhhh...
The question was how does the
proof, how does this line,
yeah where the question mark is.
So what I checked was
that this number which
is on the left hand side
is equal to this very long
complicated number which is
equal to this number which
is equal to this number.
And so I've checked that
this number is equal to 0
because the last thing is 0.
This is equal to that is
equal to that is equal to 0.
And that's the proof.
Yes?
Student: [INAUDIBLE]
Professor: So that's
a different question.
Okay, so the hypothesis
of differentiability I
use because this limit
is equal to this number.
That that limit exits.
That's how I use the
hypothesis of the theorem.
The conclusion of the
theorem is the same
as this because being
continuous is the same as limit
as x goes to x_0 of
f(x) is equal to f(x_0).
That's the definition
of continuity.
And I subtracted
f(x_0) from both sides
to get this as being
the same thing.
So this claim is continuity and
it's the same as this question
here.
Last question.
Student: How did you
get the 0 [INAUDIBLE]
Professor: How did we
get the 0 from this?
So the claim that is
being made, so the claim
is why is this tending to that.
So for example, I'm going
to have to erase something
to explain that.
So the claim is that the limit
as x goes to x_0 of x - x_0
is equal to 0.
That's what I'm claiming.
Okay, does that
answer your question?
Okay.
All right.
Ask me other stuff
after lecture.